well I've drank coffee for most of my
life my mom used to put it in my sippy
cup when I was a kid with like a lot of
milk cold brew hot brew with caramel
with milk half-and-half sugar everything
the works I have like two to four cups
every day so it smells delicious I love
it so much
keeps me wired if there's a rough
morning cold been cold okay I have
expensive tastes
so I could see this going well for me I
eat garbage so I won't be able to tell
the difference today we're gonna be
trying three different coffees at three
different price points I just want to
say these mugs are mutable off the bat I
can tell like the colors there's
different like the color on them are
quite different the middle ones light
yeah this one seems to be the darkest
[Music]
Denny's this is very sour yeah it is is
a pretty basic coffee that's coffee yeah
got nice black coffee
oh it's sugar in it oh yours I saw that
once I don't know if I'm doing it right
this one tastes like it's like your
average cup of coffee it didn't really
well me in any way now this one looks
really watery mhm like it's not as dark
of color as the first one oh yeah this
one's a bit more sour it's gonna taste a
little bit more like tea coffee I don't
take like teas I liked that one a lot
very good she's gross this is the cheap
side we don't want this
this one's very smooth mmm okay so
smooth sour strong okay this is getting
confusing
it tastes like bean water this one's my
fave
yeah I feel like this is a mixture of
yeah both of these what I want when I
want alcohol I want alcohol to be smooth
but what I want like good coffee like
you want that bitterness yeah I want
flavor I think this is the most
expensive I think this is middle and I
really just think this is the cheapest
one because like it just tastes like it
was just sitting like sitting there all
day I don't know yeah you know what no
I'm gonna actually go number two is the
most expensive this is the second and
number one is your run-of-the-mill I
think I disagree this one most expensive
want to go with this one made all I
guess and then this one was the least
expensive so it goes down like this most
expensive middle of the road
exactly what I said I know I'm sorry
that's expensive
that's jesus ismenia final answer first
one the second one was most expensive
the second one was the most expensive
what wait this is the most expensive I
just chugged the Cavani
the one that you like the best Claire
was actually McDonald's that's right and
then that's any Buster Donald's coffee
this would be really great with some oak
milk maybe a shot of espresso
Oh two sugar cubes I'm a little bit of
honey
I know something